congress has passed a bill now to  prevent a government shutdown  and keep negotiations open on cobit 19  relief  now without a deal the federal  government would have shut down at  midnight so this morning's  vote on in congress is very important  the funding extension gives negotiators  on capitol hill time to work on a proper  covid 19 relief agreement a new one  it also sets another shutdown deadline  of midnight  next friday president trump is expected  to sign this measure later today  covet 19 relief talks though they are  still stalled  however there is agreement on capitol  hill  that congress won't adjourn for the year  without passing a new bill